if you ventured inside a convenience
store recently you might have noticed
signs asking for exact change only or
even
offering to buy your change that's
because america is currently undergoing
a coin shortage or
more accurately a circulation disruption
thanks to coven 19
people aren't using as much cash and
aren't redeeming coins at places like
banks and grocery stores that means a
lot of coins just sitting in
homes and jars and piggy banks not being
used
that may not sound like a big deal if
you buy everything online but
millions of unbanked americans rely on
cash to get by
and many services like coin operated
laundromats have no other payment
options
this is likely to persist until people
start using coins freely again so
we thought it was the perfect time to
premiere this episode we shot before the
pandemic struck
about the importance of your loose
change enjoy
if you've ever used a five dollar bill
to buy something that costs four dollars
and
one cent you might have felt conflicted
about that handful of coins you received
and change
coins that will either be jingling in
your pocket all day cluttering up your
car
or slipping between your sofa cushions
you know it's money
it's worth something but maybe less than
the trouble of holding on to it
how do we get to the point where legal
tender could be considered a burden
will things ever change and until then
what should you do
with that change
[Music]
you're probably aware that pennies
didn't start out worthless
in 1913 they had roughly the purchasing
power of today's quarters
a handful of them could have bought you
a quart of milk or a bite to eat
but after a hundred years of inflation
today's pennies and nickels are worth
less than it costs to make them
no rational government would
intentionally start minting coins with
so little value
yet we seem to be stuck with them for
the time being
why is that again inflation is one of
the culprits or
rather the fear of inflation thanks to
america's weird pricing practices it's
common to see numbers
like these at checkout many people
assume that if we eliminate the penny
retailers will round up their prices to
the nearest nickel
it doesn't seem like such a big deal
when you're grabbing a soda from
7-eleven but
some economists fear that if all the
prices on
all the goods across the whole country
go up at the same time
it could kick-start a spike in inflation
others have conducted studies that
suggest this fear is overblown
sentimentality is a much more likely
reason most americans
are against eliminating the penny and 43
said they'd be disappointed or angry if
they were discontinued
without overwhelming popular support
it's unlikely that congress will abolish
such an iconic element of american
history
so u.s mints continue to roll out around
billion pennies a year more than all the
other coins combined
why so many in part because so many
disappear
into couch cushions junk drawers
fountains and landfills
americans throw away over 60 million
dollars worth of coins
every year 11 of people said they'd
rather throw a penny into the trash than
hang on to it
don't do that i know a penny isn't worth
much but there are far better places to
put them
like piggy banks not to get off on a
tangent but what's the deal with piggy
banks anyway
it's not like pigs are known for their
frugality and restraint
so what gives thank you for that
spontaneous and not at all pre-planned
question
the origins of the piggy bank are
unclear but the dominant theory is that
in the middle ages
people would keep coins in jars made out
of a clay
called pug over the next few hundred
years the vowel sound shifted from ah
to it making the word similar to the
middle english word for swine
pig by the 18th century potters were
making pig
jars in the shapes of pigs as a kind of
visual pun
and boy did it catch on unfortunately
not many of these original piggy banks
are around today
because you have to you know smash them
to get your money out
however there is a surviving cousin of
the piggy bank
a clay vessel filled with hot water that
people still use in certain places to
warm their beds
sometimes called a pig so once your
piggy bank is full
what should you do with all those
pennies nickels and dimes
unless you want to be the most unpopular
person at your supermarket we don't
recommend
using them for big purchases instead you
could pour them into one of those
machines they often have near the
entrance
which automatically sift and sort your
change and print out a receipt
you can redeem with cashier the catch
they typically charge a processing fee
often over 10 which is kind of a lot to
turn money
into money most coin machines will allow
you to
skip the fee by putting the value on a
gift card instead which is great
if it's for a place where you know
you'll spend anyway they also allow you
to automatically donate the money to one
of several charities
which has got to be one of the most
painless ways to be generous
just make sure to keep that receipt for
your taxes
maybe you'd prefer to try your local
bank but be warned
the federal government does not require
banks to accept
coins it's totally up to the institution
and will often depend on whether you
have an account there
whether the coins are rolled and even
how busy they are
and many banks are starting to charge
fees for processing coins
it's best to call ahead before you load
those buckets into the trunk of your car
perhaps the best use for loose change is
giving it to children
it's worth a lot more to them than it is
to adults it can be used as a reward for
desirable behavior teach them about math
and economics and introduce them to the
pride of saving when it's finally
redeemed
just remember to keep a little change
for yourself because one of the best
uses for it
is to avoid collecting more with just
one nickel
two dimes three quarters and four
pennies you can nail
any number that comes after that decimal
point so if you don't want to accumulate
any more
change than you already have just grab
one two three
four on your way out the door in the era
of credit cards and payment apps
it's easy to start seeing loose change
as worthless but there's a danger in
this way of thinking
if you start internalizing the idea that
a dollar fifty-five bottle of soda
costs two dollars in cash you're
basically acquiescing to a thirty
percent price increase
over thousands of transactions that can
add up
if that's not enough motivation consider
using those
savings to treat yourself to something
fun or frivolous since we tend to think
of loose changes
valueless there's less guilt in spending
it it doesn't look like pennies and
nickels are going anywhere for a while
so
whether you put it in a piggy bank
donate it to charity or give it to your
kids as an allowance
anything's better than throwing it away
but maybe get one of those piggy banks
with the stopper
just in case you get too emotionally
attached to send him to hog heaven
and that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
[Music]
you